Okay, so yesterday Donald Trump had another
one of these Corona virus press briefings.
This one was particularly bad, even by the
standards that we've come to apply to these
press briefings.
And there was something Trump seemed to sort
of just lack energy.
He seemed deflated.
It was almost like he had the wind taken out
of him just before coming out to brief the
press.
He seemed maybe out of gas is the right analogy.
He was disoriented.
He was confused during the brief presentation
part when it was time for questions.
He called on mostly friendly reporters, some
of whom ask ridiculous questions and then
just slowly walked off.
After not taking too many questions now, the
content is, of course, really disturbing.
We now have the additional contrast of Biden
Harris.
Right.
And we really start to get the sense as we
think about that and we see the continued
deterioration that almost anyone, almost anyone
would have better dealt with corona virus
than this administration.
These are just not people up to the task.
And I want to go through some of these moments
with you now.
It's it's almost becoming more sad and depressing
than anything else.
In addition to being horrifying that this
is the guy who's in charge of the country
right now.
Let's start with Corona virus from yesterday.
Again, an administration just out of ideas,
no ideas about what to do.
They have come up with what is this genius
talking point of talking about the percentage
increases in other countries.
Take a look at this.
But the virus continues to increase in nations
across the globe.
Last week, France and Germany both recorded
their highest daily number of new cases in
three months.
Not that I want to bring that up, but might
as well explain it to the media.
The seven day case average German is increased
by 62 percent since last week, unfortunately.
And that is truly unfortunate.
It's increased 82 percent in France.
One hundred and thirteen percent in Spain
and 30 percent in the United Kingdom.
Those are big increases.
Cases are also rapidly increasing in the Netherlands,
Sweden, Belgium, Switzerland, Slovakia, Estonia
and other European countries.
And in our country, they're going down.
Now, it's important to note that the reason
Trump now talks about the percentage increases
in a lot of countries is because the numbers
in those countries are still tiny.
Compared to our numbers, even on a per capita
basis.
So Trump has to say, because otherwise these
would be really dumb things to say.
I mean, they're dumb anyway.
But nobody would fall for them.
Trump has to say.
Percentage wise.
Here's what we're seeing in other countries.
Now, this is important in two ways.
Number one, the reactions in these other countries
are completely different to in the United
States, in the United States, we've been sort
of hovering between when we got down to 20000
new cases a day.
Half the country pretended like it was over.
We reopened and we got up to nearly 80000
cases a day.
We've now come back from those numbers.
So when you never really go down, when you
just have a raging pandemic in the United
States for what is now many, many months,
percentage wise, you're not going to see drastic
changes because it's just it's been bad and
it remains bad in these European countries
and other countries.
They so successfully dealt with the virus
that once you get down really low, even small
increases in terms of the number of cases
are high increases in terms of percentage.
That's one thing to understand about the sort
of just arithmetic of it.
The other piece is in these other countries,
as soon as they started to see these upticks,
they immediately say we've got to start shutting
things down, we've got to expand guidelines,
we have to tighten and expand mask wearing,
et cetera.
So when Trump points to this, the numbers
are deceptive because of how poorly we dealt
with it when it never got good.
It's just going to kind of stay bad and and
even on a percentage basis.
But we just continue plodding along like idiots
collectively.
Obviously, many of us individually are doing
the right things while these other countries
immediately react.
Now, the other thing I think it's important
to mention is just how small the numbers are
in some of these places.
You know, Trump mentions Germany.
Germany had 436 cases on Monday.
We had 40000.
And even on a per capita adjusted basis, we
have so many more cases than the countries
that Donald Trump is.
These are outbreaks that you can't even really
compare because they are qualitatively and
quantitatively so different.
Then Trump has become focused and fixated,
really almost obsessed on college football.
He wants college football to start.
Now, it's very clear Trump knows very little
about sports and doesn't really care about
sports.
And in fact, videos we've seen of Trump watching
He looks very, very bored and doesn't really
seem to get sports.
But here he is, acting like college football
is a really, really big thing that he wants
to see happen right away as we safely restore
a great economy and reopen our schools.
And hopefully we can watch colleges play football.
We want to get football in colleges.
These are young, strong people.
They want to have a big problem with the China
virus.
So we want to see college football start.
And hopefully a lot of great people are going
to be out there.
They're going to be out there playing football
and they'll be able to fight it off.
And hopefully it won't bother them one bit.
Most of them will never get it statistically,
but we will see more cases at some point and
we will eventually develop sufficient immunity.
In addition to everything else that we're
doing.
So college football, get out there and play
football.
People want to see it.
And sad for the American flag, stand for your
national anthem because people are not happy
when that doesn't happen.
Something about the billionaire president
telling unpaid college athletes to just go
out there and play and that most of them will
be fine.
That seems a little bit dystopian to me.
And by the way, is is it bad that I've been
so desensitized to Trump calling it the China
virus that I don't even find the need to comment
on that?
Is that a bad thing that's going on?
Like, it's it's become so pedestrian almost
for him to refer to it that way that it's
barely even worth a mention.
And in reality, what else is there to say
about it on the facts?
By the way, multiple college football players
have already started to develop heart conditions
as a result of catching coronavirus.
And so, as usual, Donald Trump is also wrong
on the facts.
Then, of course, Donald Trump mispronounces
Kamala Harris is name, as Kamala is concerned.
She's now my fellow Battlestar Galactica fans
will remember that one.
Kamala, I believe, was like a drug that people
took in Battlestar Galactica.
It's been a little while since I watched it,
but fact check me on that one.
I think you will find that I am.
I am right.
More substantively, sort of immediately, as
expected, Donald Trump starts attacking Kamala
Harris and says that she's nasty, she's a
woman, and she's now.
Take a look at a lot of things happening,
and so I was a little surprised that he picked
her.
I've been watching her for a long time and
I was a little surprised.
She was extraordinarily nasty to Kevin Arget.
Judge Cavenagh then now Justice Gavino.
She was nasty to a level that was just a horrible
thing, the way she was, the way she treated.
Now, Justice Cavenagh and I won't forget that
soon.
So she did very poorly in the primaries and
now she's chosen.
So let's see how that all works.
Is the nasti to Kavanaugh thing I find fascinating
because she actually had the strength to question
Brett Kavanaugh the way he deserved to be
questioned.
And, you know, these these guys like Trump,
they claim to be super alpha and powerful
and strong, and yet they can't stand up to
questioning Trump regularly, can't stand up
to questioning from female reporters.
And that seems to trigger him way more than
questioning from male reporters.
Kamala Harris asking good questions of Brett
Kavanaugh, makes her nasty in Trump's mind.
And this is definitely a preview of what we
can expect in the campaign from here on out.
They're so mean, they're so nasty.
They're being so horrible to us.
Well, you just don't like it when your narrative
is questioned, when you're echo chamber is.
That's all it is.
Then Trump again just struggling to speak
here.
He keeps repeating anarchist's for some reason
and he keeps repeating it until he gets it
wrong.
Take a listen.
It really are an outcast.
He's a left wing anarchist.
They are anarchists.
And I'm directing the department.
Very strange.
He also talked about plasma rather than plasma,
although I won't that that's like every day.
I'm not even going to play that for you.
And then lastly, again, sort of a very down,
sad Trump throwing out some last smears of
Kamala Harris before hanging his head and
just wandering away from the podium after
taking only a few questions.
Mador modify it to a point where it's essentially
no longer the Second Amendment.
I would have thought he would have gone a
different way.
Thank you very much.
So what do you think?
Does Trump gain anything by doing these press
briefings?
Kellyanne, did these press briefings, you'll
remember, stopped.
They started slowing down and then they stopped
altogether after the disaster where Trump
wondered aloud about maybe injecting bleach
or isopropyl alcohol in order to treat coronavirus.
Kellyanne Conway then suggested publicly the
reason Trump's approval is down is he stopped
the briefings and he shortly thereafter restarted
them.
And you know, what is true is that the polls
have been tightening since he restarted them.
Causation and correlation are two different
things.
And I think we can probably point to other
explanations if we want to look for them.
But is this helping Trump to some degree or
is he doing more damage?
Does it not matter?
We hear about ratings.
But at the same time, most of the country
is not watching these.
Let me know what you think.
We will have continued coverage of the fiasco,
just ghastly press briefings on the David
Pakman Instagram.
That's David Pakman show.
And we also, of course, every day have the
full hour audio podcast available around 3:00
p.m. Eastern if you prefer a long form audio
version of the show.
You don't have to watch clips on YouTube.
I love it when you do.
But if you prefer the sort of long form audio
format that you can take with you easily,
you can subscribe to the daily audio podcast
on Spotify, iTunes, Google Play, really whatever
your favorite podcasting app is.